like do you feel like that's helped you  guys stay married like not being big  into social media i think that's kept me  sane  i wanna just inject that mom the from  when she when we were young she always  took a lot of photos and always was on  facebook a lot but as the years have  gotten better she's gotten better at it  and doesn't doesn't spend so much time  doing it it definitely took away from a  lot of vacations and time spent growing  up and now it's a lot better because you  actually get to enjoy vacations and time  with her because it takes away a lot  it drop draws away your attention  completely you lose entire focus on  anything but the next like next post the  next thing